Tactics to flank slash shift a ferocious analyzer from paralysis to go.
Meaning what? Some hacks overthinks things,
hesitation to landing and planning and planning and planning.
While there's a couple of things here,
if the person is above you or below you in the chain of command,
so if they're below you in the chain of command, you know, you explained to him,
you say, look, we don't need perfection.
We're not going to have a hundred percent solution.
We don't have 100% of the information. That's a good enough solution.
We need to move forward. Let's execute. Um, and you know what?
I'll take her to things go weren't wrong, don't worry about it.
I'll take responsibility for it. I'm not going to blame you,
which is what you're gonna do anyways as a good leader.
So that's what you're gonna do for you.
They're below you in the chain of command.
If they're above you in the chain of command, guess what?
Same thing you're going to tell. Say the same thing. Like, Hey boss,
we don't need perfection here. Look, boss,
we're not going to get all the information we need.
We're not gonna get 100% solution,
we've got a 90% solution and let's go for it.
And if things do go wrong, you can blame me. I don't care. So boom,
the, whether they're above you or below you, the chain of command,
you might change your tact or your verbage a little bit, but it's the same,
same overall concept.
You've got to get them to understand that we don't need perfection,
we need to move forward.
And the other thing is you explain the cost of not moving,
the cost of staying still,
the cost of being reactive instead of proactive in basically the cost of not
being aggressive.
Cause that's what we're talking about is a lack of aggression and to what does
that look like? Will you explain to them that the longer we sit,
the better position the enemy gets into?
The longer we wait,
the less we know about what is actually happening.
Think about that one. The more you sit here and you're planning,
the less we know what's going on out there. The things are happening,
they're changing, they're evolving, the enemy's maneuvering.
There's developments on the battlefield or in the marketplace and you don't even
know cause you're sitting in the planning space. And the longer we wait,
the less time we have to recover if something does go wrong.
So if we sit here and plan for 47 days and on the 40th day we sat down and we
start to execute, something goes wrong.
Well we're not gonna make the 50 day mark cause we spent all that time planning.
So the longer that you're sitting around,
the last time you have to recover and adapt and adjust.
And the longer that you wait while you're doing planning,
the less relevant your plan actually becomes.
So that's what you need to make people understand.
Now there's people that are just habitual and chronic,
ferocious analyzers and those are the people you got to watch.
But you've got to continually just get through their head that the more we sit,
the more the enemy maneuvers. And if we let them maneuver on us anymore,
we're going to get killed. That's it. Pretty easy. No, it's not easy.
It's a simple concept.
[inaudible] it's hard to get people out of their own heads just like this.
Like everything else.
It's hard for the ferocious analyzer to recognize themselves as that.
They think they're doing a good job. They think they're a,
they think they're actually being thorough. And you're a wild man.
You're a cowboy. Hey, are you crazy? No, I'm not crazy. I remember one time I,
my first deployment to Iraq, they said, Hey John,
this is after I'd been there for awhile. And they wanted, for some reason,
they wanted to know the minimum requirements for us to go out on an operation.
And I said,
I just need a vicinity of the target and of radio frequency to talk to the local
, uh, conventional units there. And they were like, well,
don't you need air support? What she did? And I was like,
all these other things. I was like, no, we'll figure it out. Just send us. Yeah,
we'll go. And there was other things that we would do as we'd moved to a target.
We'd align things up and we'd but we, we'd be good.
But sometimes people wanted to plan out every last detail and that doesn't work.
The details are not going to stay the same.
The things that you're planning on are going to change.
So don't sit there and plan every last detail cause it's not going to help you.
Man, that's actually a pretty good plan.
Never even thought about how you say if you spend too much,
too much time planning, you know, and then you jump in the game all late.
It's like Dang, you have no time to make any adjustment can react.
Oh you better go perfect cause you, that's all it gets.
The one shot you got at it and guess what?
It's not going to go perfect cause things don't go perfect.
Things are not going to go perfect. Not going to happen.
No such thing as flawless execution.
Dave Burke just wrote an article that was on business insider.
This is what it was like. Flawless execution doesn't happen.
Well you know he was a top gun senior instructor for three years. He,
he knows about flying and he knows how hard they worked to towards fall,
this execution. But it didn't exist. The false execution was,
was analyzing their mistakes, seeing what they can improve upon.
That was flawless execution for them.
It wasn't the actual act of flawless execution. They, you know,
they had for all this debriefing, flawless analization of what they did wrong.
Yeah.
But it wasn't gonna be perfect ops then it knows no such thing doesn't happen.
So if you're sitting in planning that trying to make that happen,
it's not going to work for you. It's don't do it.